-Welcome back, everybody.
I'm here with Ana de Armas
right here.
That's what I'm talking about.
[ Cheers and applause ]
We're about to face off in a new
game called "Backtionary."
-♪ "Backionary" ♪
-Now, this is like
Pictionary with a twist, okay?
Now, I'm going to grab a clue
that I have to draw
on your back, okay?
I'll put a piece
of paper on your back.
And while I'm drawing,
you try to re-create
what I'm drawing
on that easel over there,
while you're
guessing what I'm drawing.
-Okay.
-Okay? Are you ready for this?
-Mm-hmm.
-Let's try Round 1.
Audience, clue?
[ Indistinct shouting ]
-Wow.
I like that.
Alright.
Okay. I think we can do this.
Alright, turn around.
I will put -- I will put this --
-Should I get this one?
Oh, I have the big one here.
-Yeah, you'll have
the good marker there.
Okay. Ready?
-Oh, my God.
-Alright, are you ready, bud?
I think this is
gonna be -- Okay.
Ready? Here we go.
-Wait. Slow, slow, slow.
-Yeah. Yeah.
I haven't started yet.
♪♪
-Oh.
-Yes.
How much time?
-That?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yes. What do you think?
What's your guess?
-Is it a -- It's a --
I don't know -- a --
[ Buzzer ]
-Yes. What does that look like?
That's fantastic.
Better than what I drew.
This -- yours is better
than what I drew.
[ Laughter ]
I don't know what I drew.
[ Dinging ]
Lightning bolt.
-Lightning bolt.
♪♪
-Oh, you would have got that.
-Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
-It's thunder and
lightning bolt, right?
That was good.
-Yeah.
That's good.
Alright, now -- Alright.
-Okay.
-Let's try again.
Tariq, what are you laughing at?
-Because she -- How is hers
better than the --
-It doesn't matter.
It doesn't matter.
It doesn't matter. Whatever.
It was the first round.
Okay, what clue should she pick?
[ Indistinct shouting ]
-Six. Six?
-Alright, I'm not gonna look.
-Oh.
-I'm not looking, not looking.
No cheating, no cheating.
I'm not looking.
-I like it.
-Yeah?
-Yeah.
-Okay. Okay.
-Okay.
-We got this?
-Yeah. Yeah.
-Okay.
♪♪
Wait. What? Do it again?
Sorry.
-Sorry, sorry.
-Sorry. Do it again.
Wow.
-How -- [ Laughs ]
How are you feeling that?
-I have --
I'm feeling fantastic.
I don't know
what I'm feeling right now.
Uh...
I don't know.
[ Buzzer ]
Ooh, wow!
-Wait! I'm not done.
-Oh, well,
I think one of us is --
I think -- Wait.
Do it one more time.
Yes.
I think there's a heart
on there.
I don't know what it is.
I'm going to say a clock?
A clock. Was I remotely close?
I got lost.
Oh, it was a butterfly.
A much nicer thing.
I'm sorry.
I should have gotten that.
-You're covering your --
-Mine was terrible.
[ Air horn blows ]
Ooh!
You know what that sound means.
It means it's time
for the final round.
Okay, we're going to
shake things up here.
Quest, you want to give me
a hand over here?
-Yes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Now, for this round,
we're playing
"Triple Backtionary."
Ana, you will draw on my back
and I will draw on Quest's back
and then he will draw
on his easel.
If he guesses what we're
trying to draw, we all win.
-It'll be a miracle.
-Wait. Yeah.
-It will be a miracle.
Exactly right.
-Okay.
-Ana, pick a clue.
What do you guys think?
[ Indistinct shouting ]
-Ten?
Okay.
-Okay, that's you.
No, you got that -- Oh.
-Okay.
-Alright.
[ Audience "Awws" ]
Whoa. Okay. Wait.
-They said, "Aww."
-Yeah, I know.
It must be like
a puppy or something.
Okay. Okay.
-Alright.
Ana, I'm trusting you on this.
Yep.
-I mean, you can't
get this wrong.
-Oh.
♪♪
-Are we done?
-You got to do it...
Wait. Are you doing it?
-I don't know.
[ Laughter ]
-Wait. Do it again!
Do it again! Do it again!
-I'm done.
-No, no. -- You --
Quest, no.
Quest, what are you doing?
-I'm doing what you're doing?
[ Buzzer ]
-What the heck
are you drawing, dude?
What are you drawing?
-No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Do it again. Do it again.
-One more time. One more time.
Do it again.
-I mean, mine is
pretty bad, too.
-Go.
-Okay.
♪♪
Oh.
Oh. Oh.
Oh, wait, wait.
Is it that?
-Yes.
-Well, I do more -- Yeah, mine
is different, but, yes,
that's the idea.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Dinging ]
-Whoo-hoo-hoo!
♪♪
-It was sun.
-Oh!
-Sun!
-Yes.
-I thought you were
doing a flower.
-Okay.
-That's not a good sun.
-"Questlove
has a new book out now."
There you go right there.
So he's the winner is Questlove.
Ana's new movie --
Ana de Armas --
"Ghosted" -- premieres on
Apple TV+ this Friday.
We'll be right back with more
"Tonight Show."